i got to tell you i'm excited because
i'm a definite amateur scrabble player
nowhere in the league of this guy chris
welcome to the show i understand you're
a bit of a chess fan as well um yeah
yeah i like uh watching chess i haven't
uh played it seriously uh played in high
school but um i like watching the the
broadcast on and following that um with
enough you know board game knowledge not
necessarily chess i can sort of you know
follow along with the strategies and
everything so that's really interesting
you're a resident of st louis as well
yep yep live here in the central west
end oh you even live close so you've
seen chess boom in
the in your own city not just in america
but in your own city what's your feeling
about that is there's anything similar
happening in the scrabble world
um the the booms in the scrabble world
are uh a lot of them are happening
overseas
um so yeah it's it's amazing to watch in
st louis i like to like sit in starbucks
and see if i can star watch with chess
players walking by
um but yeah in in places like pakistan
uh there's a huge scrabble scene it's on
the nightly news covered as a in the
sports section wow um yeah the recent uh
uh youth championship held online the
winner was from pakistan he got to meet
the prime minister like all this stuff
so
yeah it's in certain areas of the world
uh competitive scrabble is booming quite
a bit when you say in pakistan are they
using
which which language are they using they
play in english so yeah there's um they
play in english all over the world even
in countries where you know they using
they use it as a tool for children in
school to learn english so in places
like pakistan thailand
uh is english language scrabble's part
of the curriculum to you know try and
teach the kids english
amazing are you guys hating on the fact
that queen's gambit happened there's no
scrabble gambit or something of the sort
no we're just hoping we can aspire to
that
that's your big goal uh fascinating now
let me ask you are there any similar
strategies from scrabble that you've
seen parallel in chess
so yeah in in scrabble uh we have the
concept of tempo right because there's
you know the board and the board
position where you play your words
um so you have to kind of keep in mind
think a couple moves ahead you know if i
open up this place my opponent play a
word here so if i get my opponent to
play over here i can do this other thing
over here so there's you know kind of
you know tactics and you know keeping
the tempo in mind and stuff like that
that are kind of similar between the two
games board position absolutely matters
yeah quite a bit now a lot of people
think that scrabble is all about words
and in fact it's really about the points
yeah yeah so the words are the set of
legal moves basically so it's you know
when you uh study for scrabble you
memorize the you know hundred and
something thousand legal moves you can
make and then when you sit across the
board it's all about you know strategy
points uh trying to figure out which of
those legal moves is the best one to
make in a given situation is there
anyone in scrabble that equals magnus
carlsen in chess someone who's like a
god of scrabble everybody says all hail
this player oh yes uh his name's nigel
richards he's from new zealand uh he's
the uh you know undisputed greatest
scrabble player ever
he
probably his most famous accomplishment
he he won the french world championship
despite the fact he doesn't speak a word
of french he memorized the french
dictionary in six weeks and then went
and won the world championship
[Laughter]
it was incredible
wow
yeah wow
oh that also shows that it's not about
the words i guess it sort of is but his
strategic insight and tactical insight
must be incredible yeah yeah the
strategies and the things he does
sometimes he'll make a play and
everybody in the room is confused has no
idea what's going on and it turns out
that was by far the best play and nobody
else saw it
unbelievable nigel richards he's still
alive yep yep incredible so the magnus
crossing of the scrabble world all right
well we've got a little bit of a
challenge for you i know you didn't know
this was coming all right but we have a
little bit of a challenge for you we're
gonna do
uh
scrabble championships the chess edition
okay we're gonna pick some names from
this event
and it's gonna be three names and we're
gonna ask you to make the best words you
can
out of the names that you see so you're
going to have to make a seven-letter
word and then anything left over i'll
coax you along as we're going along but
you're gonna see let's start with one
name if you look at the screen here
we're gonna start with
sam savion you got to make a
seven-letter word and a two-letter word
there are nine letters here so you gotta
make a seven-letter word and then a
two-letter word
out of this pile uh massive
i and quick
oh impressive okay i can see it massive
and the word and is right in there okay
we started off with that we're gonna go
to another word not one of the players
this time one of the
commentators yes sir
that's 14 letters can you make two
seven letter words
out of yesterday i don't know it's
possible you're the genius here
um let's see
um
an anagram coming up
whey wires
um
there's assy
there's
swearier i think which hopefully isn't
the commentary
don't be don't be cursing
we got three s's in there as well
r is in there yeah
this is rough
but that's an eight-letter word well if
you're wearing that
wow wow
look at that yeah wow well if you could
make an eight-letter word in a
six-letter word i'll give that to you
also all right uh wearing
nice yeah did you know your name had
weariness in there no but now that i do
i don't want it to happen again
but making that six letter word with the
remaining letters is kind of hard
as you're looking at it are you just are
the words just kind of the letters just
dancing in your brain what what goes on
so i look for common groups uh prefixes
and suffixes so the ness gets kind of
put to the side and then i think about
the rest of them or an ier or you know
things like that so um chris i think you
did really good on this one i want to i
really want to see where you go with
this next one though
so you don't see anything you have to
wear it that was tricky yeah that's yeah
it's tricky to group the rest of the
letters okay well if that's tricky yeah
so we didn't know your name would be
that hard
we're gonna give you this final one you
gotta make uh
the maximum out of this
and it is
women's grandmaster good
[Laughter]
do we need uh what's his name keith
richards
yeah i need to show up with the french
chapter and also maybe the pakistani
dictionary as well
nigel could do this nigel
yeah um
let's see
anything you can make of this one will
there's uh
there's mega bit in there mega egg
mega big
bit and then
yeah yeah he's right other stuff left
over let's see um
well are there any other seven letter
words with lots of points you could spot
in here ah let's see because we did
cheat by giving you such a such a crazy
uh at least english wise
some supernova there's no supernova
there's no s
there's no s there's no p
um
wow
well megabit alone yeah was a fine these
are hard incredibly ridiculous letters
to throw at we're going to leave this
one as your challenge you got to come
back all right you got to email us to
let us know what you come up with this
one but uh yeah we thought we would try
to challenge a crazy challenge to you we
appreciate your being on the show
the world of scrabble yes sir yeah you
have some questions big i don't think
they're going to let you out of this
video
first of all
welcome to the show chris really great i
didn't know you were in central west end
come on join you're going to get an
honorable membership to the st louis
chess club come by anytime okay first
thing second thing
um
chess players you know sometimes we
marry other chess players and that's
like bishops of opposite colors i don't
know if chess players should marry chess
players in the world of scrabble
uh how about
your significant other
they
they they play scrabble with you yes
certainly uh so i actually met my wife
at a scrabble tournament um
and yeah so we started playing online
and then chatting during our games
online and yeah from there we've been
married for three years so that's worked
out yeah there's no friction in the
marriage
from the scrabble i i remember reading
the obituary of the player who
invented scrabble and he said
that his wife beat him merciful
mercilessly
how about you and yours yeah so uh i i
win most of the time we have competitive
games but yeah yeah she's uh chris
one more question in chess we analyze a
lot with the help of engines computers
that are just simply so much better than
any human does that happen in scrabble
uh yes it does actually the
computer program's called quackle that
is
probably the leading scrabble engine
that most players use
it's not to the level of the top chess
engines um so like nigel richards could
beat quackle over a long series of games
um it does a monte carlo simulation to
figure out what happens next because
it's scrabble's not a perfect
information game right there's
probabilities based on what i have in
chess as well the monte carlo
system yeah so um
if you uh
if you're playing scrabble against
another human uh you make inferences on
what letters they left behind based on
what they play um and that is still
being sort of being developed and worked
out for the scrabble engines
on how to make those inferences so um
that's kind of an advantage that humans
still have over the computer is the
ability to kind of draw in those
inferences
when will you know we we had the
singularity happen for us years ago
where chess players say oh the engines
they kill us when do you project the
engines will start dominating humans in
scrabble um the best humans that is uh
maybe within the next five years there
are some really smart programmers who
are also scrabble players working on it
still five years away you think yeah
yeah to beat nigel
yeah probably yeah
he's a he's an engineer
he's actually got a computer working in
his brain exactly well fascinating world
game world separate from chess but i
love scrabble i'm really happy to see
you on the show come by anytime oh yeah
thank you i'd love to chris live
everybody amazing insight into another
game that has worldwide following i'm
still reeling from this
memorizing french language
in six ways
without speaking a word of the language